coming up next part of femininity is
listening to your man so is it toxically
feminine if you're not listening no he
doesn't care
I think you don't always have to act on
your emotions you know women don't even
want stability and when it comes to
safety if you're kind of using you
you're safe just because you feel like
stay safe why do we watch the
Kardashians and not the NBA
I mean the women like drama women like
drama but in a relationship sense is
women are very quick to criticize but
not quick enough to praise I was a
coward in my last relationship I will
own that 100 I'm talking about friends
like actually like guy friends they
don't want to sleep with you you don't
think they will sleep with you if you
give them a window what is toxic
masculinity
um so I feel like it stems from a man
who does not know himself and he does
not know how to regulate his emotions
because men are very logical by the end
of the day they still have emotions and
they do not know how to regulate that
but they know what do you mean they
don't know how to regulate it okay so a
man knows innately in my opinion that
he's meant to protect and provide and
that he is meant to be at the head in
some kind of way I feel like that's an
innate thing that a man knows however
when um you are told that that is the
only thing that you must be and then
you're kind of
um other emotions emotions that make you
human are kind of strand you do not be
Human by emotions that make you human
because um because anything like what
emotion like um to be overtly happy or
when you said when you said the word
simp like to feel like an emotion that
is like oh I want to feel soft for this
person and all these kind of things
being soft like everything is Yin and
Yang in men and women they both have
masculine and feminine energy and you
need to embrace both of those but not
obviously too much masculinity in a
female and too much feminine material
you think you're asking men to emote
like women no no no I'm not saying that
at all what I'm saying is that you have
to understand that the as a as a man
you're going to have a little bit of
feminine energy even if it's one percent
twenty percent thirty percent I don't
know do you want men with a lot of
feminine energy and keep I said one
percent twenty percent I'm giving
variables and to be honest I don't mind
as long as you are able to fulfill your
role as a man which is to provide and
protect and to lead feet if you have
feminine energy if you're going to sit
there and I want to be I want to do some
damn feminine [__] with you and you're
going to sit there and allow me to do it
you can do that behind closed doors if I
want to do your nails and do your hair
and do your makeup we can do that behind
closed doors and that is makeup yes I'm
sorry we can't do that behind clothes
some men will not allow that no mine
yeah but this is the thing if you and I
feel like that shows what is what is
toxic masculine okay yeah can I have a
specific example okay so for example um
a man feels um angry because a woman is
undermining his authority but he's not
putting out that Authority in the
correct way so then he um unleashes the
anger out on her and starts blaming her
and all these kind of things being like
oh you don't listen Okay let me give a
specific example I believe that um a man
should make sure that his woman looks
presentable I do not want to go out any
people can have their um own opinions
but I don't want to go out looking too
promiscuous so if my man says you know
what I prefer you to not wear that and
then a woman goes um and says you know
what actually I want to wear this for
example um I might wear a top that shows
a little bit of my boobs and then my
man's like I don't want you to wear that
and I'm like actually you know what um
can I pull it up a little bit and then
it's okay and then if he's toxic he'll
he'll start getting angry like oh you're
undermining me so on and so forth and it
will turn into a big argument that it
does not have to be however if he knows
how to go about it in the correct way
then we might have a little conversation
about it and I will come to some sort of
compromise or he knows how to deal with
my emotions as a man do you think that
men want to have conversations about
problems or women want to have
conversations about problems at the end
of the day men and women are two very
different creatures there are similar to
answer the question yeah I'm a men or
women women both in both for different
topics mostly is women because we have a
lot more emotional issues so no matter
what you think don't you think you're
asking him to emote like a woman like
because often when I hear this this is
just what I've noticed is when women say
the word toxic masculinity masculinity
they're asking men to be women it's the
fact that in a relationship you have to
be able to compromise
stand you from your point of view of
things you have to be able to understand
me too if I need you to come down on a
level where I'm able to actually tell
you how I feel and I want you to
actually kind of understand what I'm
trying to tell you without fighting back
that's what I think I mean part of
femininity is listening to your man so
is it toxically feminine if you're not
listening no I think yes I think it is
because at the same time like like I
just said you need to be able to
compromise I need to be able to come to
your level you need to be able to come
to mind and that's how the relationship
should work you should be able to if I
want to sit down and tell you I don't
like this you should be able to hear it
if you want to come and sit down and
tell me you don't like this I should be
able to hear it end off I think that men
are okay with us coming to talk about
problems but it's the way we approach it
a lot of the time we approach it by
criticizing blaming shaming at trying to
control them I think if we're able to
remove all of that and we're able to
have conversations as a kind of coming
in at a different angle in in a
respectful way men are very happy to be
having these conversations in order to
you know ensure that the relationship is
on track I'm just I'm just curious I'm
just gonna do a poll quick with the guys
or do you guys want to have a
conversation with your woman about what
she wears every time you go out
oh laughs
no no okay no situation I think that you
should know yourself what's appropriate
and what's yeah that's that's fine then
but the thing is it's just a
conversation at the end of the day it's
not anything more than that which is
fine but it's just going back to the
toxic masculinity it's like you're
asking men to be women when it happens
everywhere when you're asking men to
emote like women so to have a
conversation like it's toxically
masculine if you don't want to have a
conversation but the thing is they can
have a conversation without crying
without doing this and just listen just
listen to what I have to say I'm not
asking you to be a woman I'm not asking
you to have a period every month no I'm
not I'm saying when you say it's
toxically masculine for you not to want
to have a conversation it's like when
they say something and they want to say
that's the end of conversation you get
it like this guy can come to you and say
I don't know for example like going back
to the clothes thing I don't like what
you're wearing I can try to tell you
like oh but no that's it he's not even
trying to hear your side of the story
and that's toxically masculine I think
so because it's like you're toxically if
that's a word like establishing your
dominance in a way where you're not even
trying to let me talk you're trying to
do this all like just be quiet I'm your
man kind of thing I think that's what
toxic matter I think that's just
masculinity I think like women just
don't like I'm told now nah because I
feel like you can be masculine like she
said before and come in a correct way
and you can tell me babe like I'm not
gonna lie to you I don't like the way
you're wearing this I feel like this
like at least here sorry at least hear
me out from mine but that's how women
would communicate
that's what I think that's how two
adults should communicate exactly no but
that's because you're trying to make men
communicate like women like have you
heard have you ever been in a men's
locker room and listen to how they talk
to each other and you're like oh oh I
can't believe they're like I used to
work at a plumbing tech company and they
would just roast the [__] out of each
other and I could I could not believe
they talked to each other like that but
saying oh but like that's Community they
need to remember we all women and we our
feelings do get hurt very quick so just
be aware so you wouldn't talk to you not
referring to women as children this is
just an example you would talk to a
child a certain way because you know
it's a kid you would talk to like a
bunch of boys a certain way because you
know you're in a group of a bunch of
boys just be aware of who you're talking
to that's it and and I agree with you I
think men yeah I think men know that
they know they can't communicate to us
the same way they communicate to other
men I'm saying it's not toxically
masculine it just says no under
conversation I think it is because like
it's I think just give your reason just
give your reason because that's just
what we want give your reason babe why
you don't want me to him okay this this
and this okay yeah I understand you I'll
take it off you do you think most women
that's their answer when when he says
when you give them a reason he gives you
a reason that they're like oh okay no no
it will go into a conversation I feel
like at the clothing example has messed
things up let me give you another one
okay so say for example cool I live with
my boyfriend whatever like I'm the one
who would um who will be cooking that
name say for example I say babe
um I'm thinking about making ABCD for
dinner and he goes no oh you're not
doing that I feel like why is it that
you have the right to tell us what we're
eating I'm the one that's doing it
because he doesn't want to know sorry
I'm so sorry but I've been itching I
just didn't want to interrupt anybody
it's because he doesn't want to know and
know the internet in my opinion he
doesn't want to know the ins and outs
and what you've decided just cook the
food men don't want to have to have a
conversation I like to I I think men
operate from a place of like solution if
there's a problem what is the solution
how do we fix this very black and white
it's women that want to have the
conversation so instead of the I'm
cooking tonight oh babe this is what I'm
gonna cook he doesn't care
so what if you can decide babe what
about the first of my chicken this guy
told me he wants fish are my chicken's
left foot no but they don't see him
doing that though but that's why it's
toxic
uh could you re-explain I just didn't
understand what you were saying no what
I was basically trying to say is like um
what I was saying is that's the toxic
side of the whole toxic masculinity
thing is when he wants to that apply
himself in a way where he's not trying
to hear anything else that's basically
we're just trying to be cruel I mean it
just sounds cruel like someone you say
you're going to make something this is
an example don't worry
I don't understand the situation Oh you
mean he's undermining you how is he yeah
that's what I kind of mean like that's
what I take from that from toxicity you
offer something and he tells you no like
you send the food away because I've
heard situations like that right where
it feels bad put it in the bin and just
don't want to eat it what if it was like
that
I just think that's like toxically
masculine narcissistic that's a bit far
I think the word narcissistic gets
thrown around way too quick and easy
personally I do think that you know
people don't they're not most of us are
not psychologists and we can't just
label someone a narcissist because of a
behavior which we think they're not
considered bring our feelings uh
personally I use that word very seldom I
feel like when I when I touched on toxic
masculinity it got bit misconstrued
because I didn't say not having a
conversation was toxic I mean like
exerting your dominance because a woman
is um should be subservient in a lot of
different ways and I feel like um a
certain your dominance in a way that
makes her feel
um unheard
um or just like
I'm not scared scared is too much of a
word but do you understand what I'm
saying like she can't can't be heard so
if you're so dominant that she doesn't
feel heard that's toxically masculine a
man's role as well as to provide and
protect us make a woman feel safe to do
her woman injuries if she don't feel
safe that is being toxically don't you
think I'm Gonna Change how they feel
every day
like one way I mean we all have a friend
one day she's with her boyfriend the
next day she hates him but what's her
boyfriend she's in love with him what's
she what's she doing to contribute to
the situation but we have a lot of
things going on inside like we have a
period every month that does a lot but
you know what I think you don't always
have to act on your emotions you know
you could just have the emotion yeah you
don't mean you've got to always act upon
it and I think that's where we're very
destructive when we when we're very
impulsive the moment we feel something
we thought we have to act on it you know
just sometimes ride it out just wait to
see if that feeling change if another
feeling could come and most time it will
I feel I feel like sorry just to say one
last thing I feel like I'm feeling safe
in a situation
um is something that varies like as you
said earlier love varies and all these
kind of things but for example no
relationship is perfect you're going to
have arguments you're going to have time
so you're like oh I hate him same thing
away you said that our parents might
have that but if the overall Ambiance is
safety and all these kind of things like
variance is allowable we're all humans
at the end of the day I don't even what
did you say I don't even understand what
you just said oh my gosh
um
I was just touching on the fact that um
you said
[Music]
um
I remember oh no
I was just I was just talking about I
think you said um women change how they
feel all the time and I said that um
something like stability and safety is a
relationship is going to have variance
but stability and safety is not
something that um unless you have like a
really abusive um person or something
like that that is a basis of the
relationship and the ups and downs is
just what happens in that safe space
yeah but I I think women don't even want
stability and when it comes to safety if
he's not abusing you
you're safe just because you feel like
safety is not just that safety is um
emotional safety being knowing that you
can go and have a conversation with your
man and he's going to um listen to what
you're saying and all these kind of
things safety comes in many different
forms and the women yeah it's like men
aren't here to listen to our problems
but you're building a future with that
okay why are you always going to your
goals to say if there's two men that
have a problem with each other right
what would they do
two grown men have a problem with each
other about something what would they do
um I mean it depends they might fight
what do you think oh so you think
they're just gonna punch each other in
the face straight away they would have a
conversation it's not just females it's
just grown adults generally if you're
gonna be grown I know I want stability
so bad I do because I I literally see
that as happiness yeah and I think like
women say that but then when we a lot of
times when we talk about our exes like
we're with the ones that are the most
unstable for the longest so it's like
that's why they're relaxed do I watch it
what we say as women or do I watch what
we do because I know I definitely do
want stability and my ex isn't and I was
very young as well but that's all I
don't I don't know I'm not talking about
you personally I'm talking about I'm
talking about women in general yeah we
don't we don't pick stability but we
don't know every single woman mostly
done Financial stability is the main
stability that there really would go for
uh but in regards to a guy that's kind
of
I think no one one wants a walkover
that's the thing you don't want a guy
that you can control yeah I don't think
that that that's not um I don't think
that that isn't stable like I would say
my uh my Gentleman friend that's in the
cart currently uh he's very stable and I
would only know I would only know that I
am
um I would only
I learned for I've you know I learned a
lot from my previous relationship and I
spent a lot of time on my own so from
that I know I don't want anymore and
this guy is super stable and somebody
might call it boring but I like it yeah
but I think that's like men kind of see
that as a problem because like in our
youth when we have the most of what men
value we pick the bad boys and then you
know when we're older and we have kids
then we say oh no I want a stable guy
yeah I think that I think that that's
really tricky and for me
um I I mean you know I'm 35 I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm a spring chicken
perhaps but I'm definitely in my Prime
maybe not like from a biological
standpoint in my Prime because you know
I got maybe like like a year left before
before whatever
um but I feel more I feel great I feel
small my most sexy I feel my most
confident I feel my you know I feel like
I've really and I mean you look great
but it's still not but it's still not
what men value because men value Youth
and they value Purity yeah for sure and
it's just when you're older you can't
offer that anymore so it's like when we
have the most to offer we pick the most
unstable guys yeah yeah or we're already
sucked into that with the most yeah and
it's not it's not just you know this
panel like I did Street inner I do
Street interviews all the time and
that's always what people say around 30
that's when they switch from the the bad
boys to the stable guys do you think
that women feel like they can save men
like they feel like they can fix him I
think women okay why do we watch the
Kardashians and not the NBA
watching drama
do you yeah but I don't personally like
it in my life it gives me headaches yeah
yeah because I I don't know I definitely
don't want any drama I've I've never
really wanted drama but I think yeah I
don't know what you say or watch what
you do right so who do we pick well
that's it I don't watch soap operas and
again I think even when people watch
soap operas all the time sometimes you
end up not realizing but kind of playing
out your own kind of soap opera you know
because you have that kind of mindset of
that is how life is but and yeah there
is that there is that fine line I
suppose between stability and boredom
like me I am a person that enjoys
spontaneity and not like a routine
that's one of the reasons why I work for
myself because I don't like just like
this you know same time working every
day like this mundane kind of reality so
I do think that it is important to kind
of find someone that's also willing to
kind of not just be that you know very
routine everything the same because that
that does become boring
um the next question
that he submitted is who takes criticism
easier men or women
I feel like men take it easier yeah
because women take things so personally
I think a lot of emotions and men don't
like criticism
you think men take criticism worse than
women
I think they could probably take it in a
in a work sense but in a relationship
sense I don't think they're taking I
feel like they'll take it better from
other men than from women I mean I don't
really think it matters who it's coming
from like if you I don't know if if
you've got a couple and a woman says
baby come you need to go to the gym you
know like you're putting you're getting
a little winter weight honey you know it
makes a little joke about it he will go
to the gym if you tell a woman she's
putting on weight what what then happens
I think the problem is in a relationship
sense is women are very quick to
criticize but not quick enough to praise
and then therefore that's what gets
men's backs up it's kind of like you
know I do all these good things but you
will point out that one bad thing that I
do and you will
do you think that women are never
satisfied
I think it depends on the woman
some women are what we're talking about
in general I think women are always
looking for improvements yeah men are
quite easily pleased whereas I think
women are always looking for some way to
improve the situation yeah there's
something extra I also thought one of
the comments was really interesting
about um the whole fairy tale thing and
I think so like my mind went to the
whole you know as young girls we grew up
on Disney we know about the prince
charming and this is this and this kind
of sets our ideology as far as our
husband or what we want from a man
flip that on its head I'm not too sure
if it's like that in the States but in
the UK there's this thing of I don't
know if anyone remembers being in
primary school you know if a boy pushed
you over or teased you or was horrible
to you it meant that he did that because
he fancied you and I feel like somewhere
along the lines as we've grown up and as
we've become women there is this oh if
he's being mean to me if he's ignoring
me obviously it makes you want to chase
them more because so maybe
psychologically you feel like he wants
you and that's why he's being mean to
you it's really trippy but I I find it a
lot what in some what incentive do men
have to be nice to women then well I
mean I don't I don't feel like there is
an incentive to be nice to him and I
feel like you should just be nice to
women the same way as women should just
be nice and respectful to like as people
we should just be nice and respectful to
each other but you know the problem with
that nice guys finish last but women
choose that for it to be that way if
that makes sense so as you said earlier
like the whole accountability thing I'm
not saying that men don't play a part in
the way that a woman feel tools but we
do have to be accountable and
responsible for our own emotions and for
our own decisions that we make you know
as someone else in the Super Chat
mentioned about
um
uh it just went from my mind now but
about women not understanding men and I
can kind of appreciate that to some
degree I like to think I do understand
men to a certain degree but that's only
men that I've engaged with the men that
I've come across we operate from a
completely different mental and we're
very different as human beings and I
said it last time you know men and women
do complement each other we're not the
same and I think that there's a lot of
responding and not enough listening yeah
yeah I think what you said about nice
guys finish and last like it's actually
so true because you know that as a woman
you've probably got like so many guys
that are like shouting you and doing all
of this thing but you've got that one
guy that that's not shouting you like
that you're just making that and I got a
nice guy yeah we friend zoned them all I
know literally and you've got like so
many people in your DMs you've got
people your Snapchat these are all nice
guys you're not really looking at them
the future husband is probably in the
friend zone
I don't know about that
that's what they say if you want to know
what your level is look at your friend
zone yeah my friend zone of males
especially trash bags oh wow
wait why do you why would you surround
yourself with trash bags now do you know
why I actually appreciate my male
friends the ones that are trashed the
most because they teach me what to look
out for and guys like they literally
show me but they're sitting on the sub
bench you know they're waiting for the
opportunity nah not all of them also
there's someone that's not waiting for
the opportunity I'm talking about
friends like actual Family Guy friends
they don't want to sleep with you you
don't think they will sleep with you if
you give them a window I was naive to
that when I was younger and I realized
you know what no opportunity
[Laughter]
be quiet put on speaker and say that
so
say that it's late and you're horny and
you want them to come over I'm not
saying that no no I feel like you can I
can say look I I know that this is so
Random like don't judge me but it's late
like I'm really horny I need a cuddle
tonight you're gonna tell it was not
true afterwards anyway it doesn't matter
yeah he'll see it on the stream you can
show them or even if you were to say you
were a bit tipsy and can I come over he
wouldn't he would never do it that's
what you said yeah right so you don't
need to worry I'm not saying the horny
part I'm gonna say I'm tipsy let me come
over yeah one second but I want to like
I want to be picked up first but you
need to allude to the fact that you want
to have sex with him and see if he'll
have sex with you let's see if he picks
up though I know this guy okay
hey how are you
I'm good
ready
are you gonna be home in a bit
well this is good yeah
no I mean I'm the ice cream right now oh
really why are we there yeah
when are you gonna be back
um where are you slow
I'm gonna be later
um I can get home for you I can't lie
let me see you
yeah yeah I know I know I know I know
it's [__] over here
um
let me do you know what yeah what time
you think he's gonna be home for
I don't know are you gonna be on your
own
come pick me up
all right cool whatever all right I'm
gonna shout you back
yeah let me know all right
good girl say no more say no more no
there's no say no more he thought he was
gonna come inside he's absolutely
excited I don't think so I didn't really
like that I don't know but I think not
even no he wouldn't you should have said
the rest does it come to you no I can't
do that yeah
say okay I just have a quick question
no no say it say I was just thinking
why haven't we ever dated or why haven't
we ever hooked up yeah yeah
because people come over and chill just
because exactly hello hey quick question
serious
well I hope you never did like why have
you never like spoken often
why have we never spoken often
yeah
I mean like that
like that letter yeah
no but that's why we were teal it we was
literally children back then though
the alcohol
yeah well I'll call myself you know
100 he will smash
are you skipping through the streets
right now do you still think men and
women can be friends yeah I'm a cool
number one hold up
actually I actually unless they're gay I
don't think they can now I might show
you right now hold on but I feel like
you need to be a bit more direct with it
though I have faith hey that one's a bit
too late
how many of these men have you got on
your phone I'm telling you like I've got
male friends but it's like I've known a
lot of these a lot that I'm very close
to I've known them from my childhood and
you think you're one of the boys pretty
much no no yes you don't have me
chilling around Amanda I've been doing
whatever I see them I help them link
girls and stuff so it's like oh my gosh
yeah I've had this like so much and I've
always been like yeah you could be
friends with like boys
but I've just loved from experience you
actually cannot no I think you can when
there's not an attraction if there's no
attraction there but he's probably
attracted this is the thing it's always
girls who just are like no what percent
of guys male or female friends are like
severely overweight
huh and then female friends that way
yeah like when a guy has a female friend
if she's severely overweight what
percent they're always attractive
um
I actually I'm not too sure on that one
I don't know I'm still struggling to be
to get what you mean I mean
guys guys usually pick women to be
friends with their own attractive women
so you're saying that guys only pick
friends that they're attracted to
that they consider attractive in some
way or that the only connection of like
you guys initially sparking up a
conversation would be based on oh let me
go chat to her unless you're like
neighbors and you've grown up together I
guess the real question is can you be
friends with a guy then he wouldn't
sleep with you
I'm not doing that again
I I want to say yeah the I really want
to say yeah you can but I don't think so
I think if you're attract if you're an
attractive woman and you've got
substance about you even forget the
substance if you're an attractive woman
if you really wanted to you could sleep
with any of your friends whereas we're
the ones who say I don't want to cross
that line you know with such good
friends
they're not afraid to press that line
one bit apparently you're what 21 yeah
yeah you'll learn
any of them you're attractive woman any
of any of them yeah trust me yeah I
haven't
don't think I've I can't think anything
of my right now but I think I like to
think if I wanted to sleep with any of
my male friends I probably could
if I put it on them like that I could
not that I want to I just had to clarify
my friends are my friends
there's none there's none sweetheart
it's all right you got you got someone I
mean look it well we'll take the content
hold on
no
here's my most platonic friend let me
think oh that's risky
now because that one the friendship will
end if it gets sour no they'll see
afterwards anyway this is just for the
for the sake of the out of the point
that we're trying to prove here yeah
they'll see it you can just send them
the link yeah I was just joshing I was
just kidding should I okay do it ah I'm
here for all of this
nah that's Pete nah that one's Pig you
know the one I've been calling brother
for years I don't need that because if
that goes left that's again we should
just see yeah just see because you're
confident that he won't write he's your
friend
are you sure I find this crazy as well
but it's actually I literally don't
think you can be friends with straight
males like
attraction if you're attractive then
that's it it would the man will rise for
the occasion I mean you can't yeah you
can't be friends with them without them
wanting to sleep with you that's scary
and they will only sleep with you if you
allow them to if you say no forever then
they won't as simple as that would
do you think then it's disrespectful to
have male friends in a relationship
oh maybe like if you're like
acquaintances not ready but if they're
like friends and they're over absolutely
because how would you feel if the roles
were reversed and he had a bunch of
girls wanting to sleep with him all the
time I would but the thing is until just
now I didn't know that
oh my God
I can't lie especially like with this
guy here I've been I've hooked him up
with people like I've been friends with
some of his girls and that like I've
been tight with his girls I never
actually thought in my head it was that
loud would you would you date him no
just telling him a dream right there see
this is the thing I think I think if you
have a male friend who thinks that he
could sleep with you then no
that that's not a healthy situation no I
mean no you know come on we know she
didn't know what if one of the roles
were reversed and your boyfriend had a
girl yeah if if he ever said yes like
she would be down 100 however he's told
her now are you cool with that no I know
she's like no that actually happened
with my boyfriend he's told me like a
friend of his wanted to sleep with him
and he said no but I remember she was
there when we went out on a night out
and
she was all over him as well and it was
just a lot like I couldn't stand it it
wasn't a thing it's not a thing it's not
yeah yeah yeah yeah is it different do
you think though when you're like I'm
just trying to think because I have got
a couple of male friends I've got male
friends
that's why I can't get over how red I
look I've never wearing red again or
something like this um
um but I think when you're both like in
a relationship say he's married and I'm
married I think maybe that's different
because I prefer it because I've had
actually an example of a male friend
um and we were really good friends and
it just got to a point where I mean he
did Express that he felt something in
that sense towards me and it obviously
made it awkward because I was also
friends with his wife
um and I kind of just said he said that
while he was married yeah wow he did a
Pamela so we've not we've we've kind of
cut the contact now but you know I kind
of said before actually do you know what
in the situation before he said that we
can't just be friends you and I it's
either like we're friends as couples or
not at all kind of thing and he didn't
want to be friends as couples because he
actually felt uncomfortable with me
around his wife because he felt an
attraction towards me so that kind of
messed up the Friendship there so I
think that yeah it's I think it's okay
like if you're friends of a guy but he's
got a wife and you're friends with a
wife and he's friends with your husband
like that sort of thing now as a woman I
feel like
to make the other women comfortable like
you always just need to make ties with
her like even with my friend with his
girls like I've always been that girl
who's like all that hey like if we're
chilling together like say we had a
drink up or something I'm gonna go to
her I'm gonna chill with her yeah I'm
gonna see how she's doing like leave him
for a second it's a respect thing yeah
it's a respect that look I'm not I'm not
a threat to you exactly I want you to
know that I'm not a threat to you and I
think I think if if your friend who you
friend zone let's say for example yeah
okay if I gave you a window you would
jump through the window but understand
I'm never giving you a window so if you
are happy to settle for that then that's
up to you that's your decision you have
to be accountable for that
um and you have to respect me and my
partner and if there's any tinge of
disrespect you've got to go yeah I agree
as long as that person is because I feel
like some guys will try to slightly just
like throw shade on your mind if that
happens it's like no we can't be friends
but also it makes me think like
but they just sleep with you because say
they would sleep with anyone who's like
attractive and so if you come on to them
why would they say no if you're a friend
or not because they would sleep with
someone who's attractive who they don't
know who that you know what maybe it's
not just sometimes conflict with someone
who's not attractive maybe it's not just
because you're friends with them but if
they've never seen you like that and
then you turn to them and say that to
them why would they turn it down because
they would do it on a night out anyway I
feel like that's a little bit naive I
think I think I think obviously men are
very visual in my opinion men are visual
creatures right they are visual and if
you look good then you know it's
potential blood can be rushed into
places but ultimately you look good and
they acknowledge that you look good but
if you couple that especially in today's
society where substance is so dwindled
if you know what I mean women some women
tend to not have any substance or any
depth to them so if they're your friend
you're already cool so that's one
element you probably got a good head on
your shoulders which is another element
there are there are things about you
that they know that probably are more
attractive if if that makes sense now
they don't need all that just to sleep
with you though no they don't but but
then they wouldn't need to but why why
are they maybe not why they yeah why are
they friends with you there's a reason
why your friends you have a connection
I'll be best friends or are we just
friends I'm friends with a lot of people
so it doesn't have to be on like a deep
but it depends on level yeah sorry I
didn't mean to cut you so but then I
guess I don't know for me I I the friend
I don't use the term friend Loosely you
can be an associate that's okay you
could be a colleague that's okay you can
be just somebody who I know in passing
that's okay if I call you a friend with
deeper level than that you can come to
my home you can be around my kids you
can be around my partner that's okay an
associate you can't come into my house
as an associate because there's
different levels to it but I have heard
uh should I say like friend boys online
or like acquaintances of mine say they
started talking to a long-term friend of
theirs like in a different way and then
they would be like funny I've never
looked at her that way I've heard that
before
I have no I know at the moment the
moment she says come over I'm a bit
Randy
it didn't happen like that it didn't it
started like with them did they end up
hooking up yeah ended up being boyfriend
and girlfriend oh so you know then he
did look at her like that but not at the
beginning exactly I think that what
she's I agree with what she's saying
because it's like
at the end of the day you can be in a
relationship with someone or you can end
up getting with someone that you've been
friends with but it would not have
started off like that like they could
have seen you in a whole different light
but until you actually put it out there
they didn't think twice about it like
before it would have been like oh yeah
this is my boy well I'm with my partner
we were friends for several years before
we got together and I did ask him you
know did you ever look at me that way
type of thing and he will say well no
because I was in a relationship and he
always tried to keep himself looking on
his good behavior in that sense but the
more and more I delve like yeah but did
you ever find me attractive whatever
then obviously he will go well yeah
obviously I found you attractive I think
it's more like maybe he didn't see an
opportunity yeah and then she gave him
signals so do you guys think that every
single male in your life that you're not
related to has looked at you like that
yeah maybe I mean whether they have or
whether they haven't if you offer it up
they're gonna take it [__] but what if
they don't no but they would
but
well it's funny too because if you ask
guys about this
like they'll tell you like they know how
like if you ever heard a guy say I know
how men think yeah
[Music]
um I'm gonna Read Super chats and then
we're gonna watch a video
um okay
bodybuilding lifestyle my best friend
slept with my girlfriend it's a no
Carlos X most men have low standards for
one base home run don't flatter yourself
most of your guy friends can get busy
and go right back to the Ball Game black
is Panther
um those those call her friends is
exactly what we're talking about dudes
do not talk to their male friends like
that dudes were talking to her men code
switch because women can't handle the
truth LP Berkshire um Pearl is the goat
um Chief Keef I mean that's why women
deserved last Myron gains
um Pearl I asked what parent takes
criticism what parent takes criticism
better zero Fallout one the problem is
women go on to marry the stable oh I
read that one already uh blessing can we
watch the video
yeah
relationship like now with Tommy are you
are you in touch with him at all or uh
do you just kind of I mean text here and
there you know nothing nothing too crazy
I mean he's married and and happy and
she's good to him and I I totally
support that and think and think that's
great so I mean I hate to be annoying
and going through this again and for
sure she's annoyed but
um I respect their relationship and just
glad he's happy and he has somebody in
his life do your boys like him or are
they estranged they do they like him no
they they see him all the time I see him
all the time and I think that this movie
too is kind of like a love letter to
their parents they know they come from
True Love they want people to see the
real story and I thought that was kind
of cute and kind of charming and and
really you know Brandon um is very
artistic and really wanted to show the
story from
it was really it was really well done
and and I enjoyed it sometimes I I found
myself going I wonder if I said to Pam
well do you have any regrets like do you
think there were certain things in life
or would you just do it all over the
same exact way it was it was it a fun
ride or was there there was there was a
tragic or miserable what how do you
assess it it was all of it but it was
more good times than bad and
um
yeah I wouldn't do it any other way I
mean I just feel like it was just this
wild wild ride and I made it home in one
piece I came back to the place I grew up
in I bought the house of my grandmother
and I'm living in it and I'm looking at
my life from the same place my feet
touched the ground when I was a baby I
mean I'm right I look at it all like a
movie
do you think women learn from their
mistakes typically
maybe they have to be repeated again and
again to learn I think I think they
learn eventually yeah it's difficult to
learn things from the first time of
making a mistake I think so I think it
depends on the woman oh sorry I don't
mean to call you I think it depends on
the woman and where she is in a in a
life probably not but there are some who
do but in general you would say no I
mean I can only for me I learn but in
general I probably think no no what do
you think most women are in a vicious
cycle maybe this never ends yeah
they're chasing something what do you
guys think do you think in general women
learn from their mistakes or no like I
said eventually but it takes it takes a
little it takes a while to get how many
how many times
let's say on average maybe three
three times for how many years oh how
many months I'd say three times with the
person like I feel like in terms of
learning yeah I feel like in terms of
learning your mistakes as well it comes
into growing up and your age and stuff
like the same chances I would have given
someone I don't know a few years ago I
wouldn't give them no like that would
take me longer to let I mean take me
quicker to learn than it would have
before if that makes sense what do you
think
um yeah I think it definitely depends on
where you are in your stage of growth
and what you have experienced before and
how you've um reflected on that
do you think men should date women that
have dated bad boys in the past
women do you think would you do you
think that men should date women that
have dated bad boys in the past why not
I think they might have an attitude
women who date about boys and plus I
think I was talking about you we're
talking about in general I think that
there were pros and cons to it I think
from for a man who has dated for a man
who dates a woman who has dated a bad
boy in the past you would hope or you
would think that she would learn from
the mistakes of the bad boy and
appreciate the good guy right and then
on the flip side of that I guess there's
a posit there is a negative because a
guy who dates a woman who's dated a bad
boy before she will have this
trauma this trauma or she may bleed on
him when he didn't cut her if that makes
sense so I feel like there's pros and
cons too it's like almost the man of the
future have to pay for the mistakes of
her past I feel like everybody has to
pay for the mistakes of people's pasts
if you're not healing from it and you're
not learning from it for sure I mean I'm
sure we've all at some point had a guy
that's like trying to go through your
phone because some girl cheated on him
before do you know what I mean yeah yeah
taking your thumb and unlocking your
phone when you're sleeping yeah all of
that stuff experienced it all yeah I
think it's more high risk for a guy
obviously to get involved with woman
that's had a bad past but a lot of men
do like to play the hero
you know what I feel like I feel like
even though sorry do you want to go so
this is save a whole that's what I was
saying
polite
funny enough even though men come across
with the stronger personalities than us
I feel like when it comes to
relationships and being emotional I feel
like they are kind of more fragile in
the sense where you some women will hurt
a man and it will stay with him for his
whole life whereas with a woman even
though we do get her and it will take us
a while to get over it we're not gonna
portray that in every single situation
he talks about our exes more men or
women
women the the party we might talk about
it but their demeanor will change like
the way they act and the way they
actually carry themselves with change
because of one relationship that's what
I've seen so do you think that men are
not as resilient as women or do you
think that
that men in certain situations allow
themselves to be vulnerable allow
themselves to trust a woman and she
shits on it and that's why it hits him
just as hard because he that is not a
man's default necessarily and maybe they
just learn what works and what doesn't
you know men are problem solvers do you
know what I say so if they treat a woman
like a queen and she treats him like
[__] and then they realize oh if I if I
treat her worse she treats me better do
you know what I think I think I'm like
oh I'm gonna pick when it comes to
thinking I think men think with logic
women obviously you think of emotion I
feel like emotionally it's easier to
heal yourself than logically because I
feel like logically you're going to be
thinking okay so the positive woman did
this to me I need to now watch out for
this in the third one whereas where
certain women are emotional it's going
to be I don't know they're gonna be more
points to forgive if that makes sense
move on if that also makes kind of sense
yeah no it does make sense I I get where
you're coming from and I definitely
think
it's biology women operate from you know
the emotional side and men tend to
operate from The Logical side but I
think that I don't know I'm definitely
an emotional woman I feel everything
very intently but my experiences have
led me to be very logical in my decision
making right so it's like I can sit
around and I can be upset that my
relationship ended or let's say
hypothetically a guy cheated on me right
I can sit around and oh my God but I
just feel so worthless what was it oh I
can okay cool look
oh all right that's not really the best
example to give but you can look at
something logically and be accountable
and forgive yourself and then you don't
need to chase the whole emotion thing if
that makes sense the whole yeah I kind
of know where I was going with it but I
don't know I hear what you're saying but
at the same time I feel like cool in the
same situation where we would be on the
emotional side of things like I said a
guy will not be logically thinking okay
so cool this guy has done this to me
now I'm gonna do this to prevent this
from happening again and now he's gonna
start building up that kind of himself
that kind of wool you get it so it's
gonna be a thing where now maybe he
didn't used to act like this before but
he acts like this now because of what
he's been through but it's not
necessarily emotional not necessarily
emotional it's now kind of wired into
like a problem solver yeah it's a
problem solver so this was the problem
and this is how I'm gonna solve the
problem by not letting everyone else in
it's like I can get the youngest hottest
women by treating them like [__] because
that's what they want or that's at least
what they're alluding to what they want
yeah I think the only sorry exception to
that about talking about exes is when a
man has been divorced I think that they
do that that really plays on their mind
and that that's very difficult for them
to move past
what is one thing
that you did wrong that contributed to
your last relationship or a relationship
ending and you cannot say I just
overlooked a red flag I can take this
one okay I was a coward in my last
relationship I will own that 100 I was a
coward and I was scared and I wasn't
honest and I was
Allied and
and I think if I hadn't have been so
cowardly in the last year of our
relationship
we would have parted it wouldn't we
wouldn't have had the war that we had if
I was braver and I weren't so scared of
the repercussions
yeah okay I'll own that I know that this
is going to make me sound really bad but
there he goes
um that one I'm not entirely sure if
this was the real reason or it was an
excuse for him but what ended up
happening was long and short of it at
the start of the relationship he cheated
on me and then he came back asking me to
marry him and then I actually said yes
and then I went back and said actually
no I don't feel like marriage is where
we're at right now and it was it
actually did become a bit of an on and
off relationship actually I said I
haven't done enough but in hindsight it
was more on and off as in breakup for a
few days and back together you know a
lot like a long period and the last time
that he came back he said to me
um like you know let's get back on
together and I said actually someone
previously that I dated had got back in
touch with me and we had arranged to
meet up for a drink and I honestly said
actually I'm not ready to get back for
you yet I've got a date in the diary
with this x um that I just actually want
to see whether or not I still feel
anything towards this person and that
was kind of a big smash to his ego and
he for him that was the final straw
you saw an ax while you guys were dating
no once we'd broken up and I thought it
was the end I somebody from my past had
reached out to me
so I don't know so what was the what
were you what's your accountability for
the demise of your last relationship
maybe because he wanted to feel like I
was the one and only man ever for him
and that I wasn't looking at another
option now but you're talking about him
what was your accountability what do you
think you did sorry pal
by showing that I still wanted to
explore other options I guess
okay I don't know if that was wrong for
that maybe not I don't know I'm confused
because I thought that was after you
guys broke up so it was on he kept
breaking up with me and then getting
back together like a week later okay so
in between that so the time that he
actually came back and said okay let's
get back together I said well in the
interim period once you when you broke
up with me my ex got in touch and I'm
arranging to meet up with him so before
that like what do you think contributed
to him like breaking up with you oh
um insecurity because I called off the
engagement okay and he felt that I
didn't forgive him for the cheating I
guess okay not being able to let things
go yeah okay go ahead
okay
um what was the question again
um what is something that contributed to
your last relationship ending
um that that you did that I did yeah and
you can't say I ignored red flags
I think what happened was first of all
we all know I was very young my I've
only had two boyfriends so it's this one
I've got now
and the one before
I think because I have like a real
passion for something as well and I
studied it when I was in secondary
school
obviously I had to go home because it
was long distance and Face Time him and
it was quite a lot especially when you
have to wake up at like six in the
morning every single morning and then
train until six two and I think I
honestly
I think it was quite natural I think it
was just like I can't do this anymore
I'm also a bit young for you and I don't
know what I want also
I if anything I just kind of wanted to
focus on what I was doing because so you
just weren't that invested in the
relationship yeah I think in the end at
the start I really was and then
I just thought also am I
like just in this to just be in this
because I did have such a deep feeling
for him but
then again I was so young to even
know what it was really I don't know
whether it was just
I Loved Someone loving me or I don't
know yeah you're only 21 or 22 yeah 21.
everyone's like she's only had two
boyfriends I'm like gosh she's 21. yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible